في البدايه طالبان يعني نشا واصدرت هذا
القرار لانهم عن قصور في الدبلوماسيه لدى
طالبان وكذلك انه الجناح المتشدد في
طالبان يطغى على الجناح المنفتح داخلهم
اذا كان هناك منفتح يعني
لكن طالبا نصره هذا القرار هو قرار متشدد
هي خطه من زعيم طالبان وتعيينه لوزير
التعليم العالي وقبله بشهر تعيينهم لوزير
التعليم العالي
وزير التعليم في منتصف نوفمبر وبمجرد وصول
المنصب الجديد له في اول تصريح له بدا
يتهجم على جامعه الفتيات ومن ثم تهجم على
الحكومات السابقه في افغانستان وحتى على
الملوك لانهم نشروا الانحلال والفساد في
افغانستان وسابق ذلك تعيين وزير التعليم
العام في طالبان بانه نحن امام مساله وقت
فحسب ستغلق حتى المدارس الابتدائيه في
افغانستان
تمنع الفتيات من التعليم تماما من
الابتدائي نعم نعد الى ما كان عليه بين 96
و 2001 هذا هو المتوقع من الطالبان يعني
فهذا من ناحيه هو قصور عمل الدنماسي وان
الجناح المتشدد داخل طالبان يطغى حتى على
الجناح الذي يحاول ان يكون منفتحا على
الغربه وعلى المجتمع الدولي